remember Marcus Markovich you gotta make
that
he got fired Marcus get off the court
idiot
Mr Markovich I will offer you community
service coaching adults with
intellectual disabilities
no boo-boo words okay fellas we're gonna
do a simple ball handling exercise my
girlfriend loves this
foreign
they just need to feel like a team
ah we're gonna need some help you're
getting a player off the injured list
welcome to the team cosentina what's
with the boogie board you do you lie to
me okay where do you got this guy he
just showed up one day
this is my sister Alex gonna do a couple
karaoke with us
you know the game better than anybody
you got a defense over here you got to
learn to build relationships I'm new to
all this yeah you can tell hey we got
next Don't make me say it make you say
what
that's a boo-boo word we got next
coach just doesn't feel right
I should be coaching in the NBA well
No Doubt
you can get this team to the Special
Olympics finals
you might be ready to be back in the NBA
we've been following your incredible
story coach Marcus is just one win away
from qualifying for the regional
tournament I don't know if you're brave
or crazy
I know this is your shot at being
champions
foreign
problems that was fun you were passable
I don't have a girlfriend makes sense oh
what am I that bad looking
you know McConaughey